animals don't set out to teach us
anything at all but we all have a lot to
learn from our interactions with them
nevertheless imagine that we come back
from work unusually late it's been a
tricky day a threatened resignation an
enraged supplier a lost document to
delayed trains but none of the mayhem is
of any concern to one friend waiting by
the door uncomplicated ly pleased to see
us PP a two-year-old border terrier with
a continuous appetite for catching a
deflated football in her jaws she wants
to play in the usual way even if it's
past nine o'clock now with us in the
chair and her sliding around the kitchen
and unexpectedly so do we we're not
offended by her lack of overall interest
in us it's at the root of our delight
here at last is someone wholly
indifferent to almost everything about
us except for our dexterity at ball
throwing someone who doesn't care about
the Brussels meeting who forgive us for
not warning the finance department in
time about the tax rebates and someone
from the Lisbon conference is beyond
imagining one of the most consoling
aspects of animals and it might be a dog
a sheep a lizard or a people is that
their priorities have nothing whatsoever
to do with our own perilous and tortured
agendas they are redemptive ly
unconcerned with everything we are and
want they implicitly mock our
self-importance and absorption and so
return us to a fairer more modest sense
of our role on the planet a sheep
doesn't know about our feelings of
jealousy it has no interest in our
humiliation and bitterness around a
colleague
it is never emailed on a walk in the
Hills it simply ambles towards the
pathway on and looks curiously at us
then takes a lazy mouthful of grass
chewing from the side of its mouth as
though it were gum ducks nibble at the
weeds waddled down to the water and
paddle about in circles without any
interest in which century it happens to
be from a human point of view they've
never heard of the economy they don't
know what country they live in they
don't have new ideas or
Rett what happened yesterday they don't
care about the career hurdles or
relationship status of the person who's
sprinkling a few breadcrumbs near them
time around animals invites us into a
world in which most of the things that
obsesses have no significance which
correct are characteristic over
investment in matters which make only a
limited contribution to the essential
task of existence which is to be kind to
make the most of our talents to love and
to appreciate we believe in making the
world a more emotionally intelligent
place and to that end we've now also
published some extraordinary books as
well as other merchandise that
reinforces some of the themes
illustrated in our videos please click
on the link below to see more